hello everyone and welcome back to the
match josé raúl capablanca versus juan
Corzo it's the ninth game of the match
so so far we've seen how well we've seen
only two games but the first two games
in the match were lost by capablanca
then he adapted to the playing style and
to his opponent then he won't two games
we already won one game that he won but
both of the games that he wants so far
the one we've seen and one in Game four
the one where he avoided the Evans
gambit Anwar went for the 2-2 nice
defence were with the black pieces so
here kappa blanka has the white pieces
and it's really just a wonderful game
I'm sure you'll enjoy it
and with the white pieces kappa blanka
opens the game with d4 which in those
times this this match was played in 1901
we've already said that but the d4 in
those days was considered to be a lesser
move not for stronger tournaments or
anything but the kappa blanka who didn't
know openings who didn't know any
opening theory he just played what made
sense to him and what he considered to
be a principled move it wasn't until
1904 when hairiness and Pillsbury
finished the first ahead of Emmanuel
Lasker in a very strong tournament that
d4 was acknowledged to be a top-tier
move for four very strong tournaments I
believe a year ago or maybe more I made
a video I called it the de man who
invented the d4 it features the game
between Harry Knowles and Pillsbury and
emmanuel asked her I will put a link to
it in the description below it will be
the first thing you see so maybe if
you're interested in all our games you
you want to check that out as well but
okay d4 by capablanca and now d5 Knight
to f3
we have c5 by concourse of the cross
variation in those days white still
didn't go further for the c4 the Queens
gambit but as Capablanca wasn't aware of
any opening theory does it does really
come as a surprise III defending the d4
pawn and Knights the c6 and okay b3
preventing black from expanding with c4
and also preparing to fianchetto the
dark square bishop we have e six Bishop
to b2
Knight to f6 and now Knight bTW to both
players simply continue developing their
pieces on on optimal squares
see captures on d4
after some before and now Bishop to d6
and you can see that both white and
black have excellent development black
has already two nights out the bishop is
out black is ready to castle but as in
most cases where white opens with pawn
to d4 black will have some problems
developing the the light square Bishop
and the Queen side rook Bishop to d3 we
have castles kappa blanka also castles
and now comes Knight to h5 here one
Corzo once the push f5 and also if
capablanca allows it may be playing
Knights to afford to attack couple long
a strong bishop on d3
so couple blanca prevents this g3 takes
away the DF for square from black's
knight and now comes f5 creating a very
strong outpost for this knight on e4 so
tonight it will now jump back to f6 and
go to e4 if needed with Knight to e5
cover Lanka also creates a very strong
outpost for his knight on e5 Knight goes
back to f6 and now f4 and okay black can
either allow this night the remain on e5
one courser decides to eliminate it we
have Bishop captures pawn captures on e5
and now which Knight to e4 it's probably
the the most correct move you can either
now have the same choice you can either
leave this very strong Knights to be any
four or you can exchange and then after
a pawn captures the F line opens and but
it will always be a better position for
white so here one course we instead of
Knight e4 goes Knight g4 already looking
for adventure the idea is 93 of course
the attack the Queen and the rook
Capablanca defends at Queen e2 and now
comes Queen to b6 going after the d4
pawn Knight to f3 couple monka improves
the position of his knight also now the
bishop and Knight defended the d4 pawn
Bishop to d7 developing finally the
light square bishop now this rook can
also come into the game a3 taking away
the be 4 square from one course was
Knight and King to h8 now there's the
possibility of this Knight Rema nuvaring
from perhaps h6 the g8 to e7 or maybe h6
f7 then to push g5 maybe open up the G
file play room g8 a lot of attacking
ideas for black were possible
Capablanca kicks away the night h3
six and now Queen to f2 preparing the
King g2 but also the queen is now
controlling the d4 pawn with the bishop
so now the knight can move Knight to f7
preparing g5 and now comes King G to
improving the position getting out of
this diagonal and now g5 and here a
couple of Anka plays a very interesting
G for a very nice move it's also an
attacking move black can never afford to
the capture here because after this
point is captured look at this very
strong bishop the rook is coming to h1
it will be impossible to repel this
attack you mean you can even double up
rooks here bring the other look into the
th file as well it will be simply too
much for black to handle also you don't
really have the option of pushing f4
White will still open up the position
with h4 and go rook h1 bring the other
look there it will be again overwhelming
for black
so after g4 we have 97 controlling the
f5 square but also maybe preparing an IG
6 to come to f4 or h4 if needed we have
Quinta III by capablanca preparing
Knight capture son g5 so Quan Corso
defends the Jeep on and now comes Luke
81 now the final rope is developed and
we have Knight to g6 preparing Knight f4
check or perhaps Knight h4 check well it
depends on what kappa blanka plays first
Kappa goes for G captures on f5 and now
we have Knight to f4 check we have King
to h2 and now comes Knight captures on
d3 eliminating Kappa Blancas very strong
light square Bishop Queen captures and
undie 3 and now comes he captures and fi
finally recapturing the pawn here and
also we have a two very strong pawns
here if this g4 advancement is about to
happen then it can be very dangerous for
kappa blanka but we have c4 here as you
can see capablanca has this very strong
dark square bishop here who so far
wasn't really a part of this game other
than protecting the d4 pawn but if you
look at the King on h8
then if the position opens up let's say
you the the d5 and d6 are played then
the black King will be in a lot of
trouble so here is perhaps the best idea
is the simply start attacking
g4 but one Corso wants to prevent this
pawn from being pushed here and also he
wants to bring the Queen into the game
so here he plays Queen to e6 but this
simply doesn't work and it is up to you
capablanca of course figure out why
doesn't work but you can also figure out
why it doesn't work by pausing the video
here and trying to figuring out the
correct response I will give it a couple
of seconds as usual for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
are an excellent player and for those
who just won't enjoy it show a couple
Bunker play seek after Sun d5 and now if
you just move the Queen then e six is
coming so you have to capture on d5
Queen captures and now comes the move
you had to find a six regardless of the
fact that these exponents are protected
twice
you cannot capture with the Queen of
course the rook is covering the pond but
if you capture with the bishop this
still doesn't work because rook captures
and now if Queen captures d5 this comes
with check and you lose the Queen not
only you lose the Queen but after you go
up the Queen you have to give up the
rook and you are now getting checkmate
it
yeah it's an easy game for white so
after each six one course it does have a
move he plays Bishop to b5 he attacks
the Queen and here a couple bunker could
simply move the Queen give up the rook
pick up the night and he will have a
very strong attack but Capablanca
decides to play this game with with
great style and he goes for Queen
captures on b5 removing the Queen from
d5 so he can advance the pawn Queen
captures on b5 so a very nice Queen
sacrifice and now d5 this comes with
check Black has to make a move you can
just give up the knight but then the
knight would be captured and you would
again have to give up your rook so first
look to g7 and here comes ecat force on
f7 so what do you play here it's a very
delicate position you cannot move the
rook the rook is pinned you have a very
dangerous pawn here the Queen has to
keep an eye on the EI square constantly
if you play something like Queen
captures on d5 then rotate check will
win you the game rook captures
we have pawn captures bringing a queen
into the game and then after the Queen
blocks still
can block with the rook as the rook is
pinned from the bishop Queen blocks and
now you can play anything rook e1 and
it's it's it's a it's game over
let's say six Knight captures you still
cannot capture with the rook if you
capture the Queen then you're just down
too much material after you capture this
comes with two Czech Queen 87 Loki 8
will be checkmate just a couple of ideas
what would happen if the Queen ever
leaves control of d8 square so here one
course of played h6 but there really
isn't isn't much better move to do and
this comes with the idea of moving the
King to h7 of course you want to unpin
so you would force a White's to capture
here but at least you will be able to
move some pieces and the White will lose
a very strong piece here a couple one
goes Knights to d4 there was a better
move but we're going to get back to that
as it's it's a bit of a long story
sorry about that Knight to d4 comes with
an attack on the Queen and here you
don't have the luxury of moving the
Queen if you play Queen d7 or something
Knight captures and f5 is coming and
then I mean there's simply too much
pressure here you cannot even block as
the point is also controlling the the g8
square here you would have to capture an
f7 and then comes the Bishop captures
King to h7 and now rook to e6 there's
not much you can do
rook captures and h6 is coming if you
play something then you can even get to
checkmate it but you are losing the game
either way so here after a couple
Blancas Knight d4 Concorso does not
retreat but rather he he grabs the rope
here Queen captures an f1 and then this
is most likely the move Capablanca
missed otherwise he would have found a
better refutation of this h6 move but
like I said we're gonna get back to that
so Queen captures on f1 we have rook
captures on f1 and not rook captures on
f7 finally getting rid of this pawn
there are no any there aren't any good
discoveries here you cannot connect the
Knights jump to any of the rooks so
first row captures an f5 rook captures
and Knight captures an f5 King to h7 and
now you can see couple Lanka has a
knight and the bishop against the rook
of course this is
better better in itself but here someone
would someone would go perhaps you could
start improving the position with your
King you could start pushing the past
pawn but the move capablanca place is
the absolute best here kappa blanka
plate knife to e7 and now when you see
this you understand that black is
completely lost and there is no move
black can make because the bishop and
the knight create a wall here against
the black King see the knight is
controlling the knight is controlling g6
and g8 and the bishop is controlling g7
so the black King can never approach the
position and there are no useful moves
for black if you attack the knight
simply d6 is coming in your Knight is
stuck there d7 is coming so here at one
course to continue the game he played
rook to f8 one course also found a very
interesting idea that he can use to his
advantage
King G to Kabul Anka prevents rook F to
check but also starts bringing his King
into the game we have h v d6 now starts
pushing his past pawn g4 h captures H
captures and now Bishop to e5 the bishop
now is guarding this pawns of the night
is free to move and here the night in
which trip still create a wall against
the black King and if the black King is
ever to enter the position you have to
enter the position via h6 but here's the
problem
King h6 is indeed perhaps I mean it is
the engines favorite also but it simply
doesn't work not that the king is on h6
kappa blanka can further advance his
passport we have d7 rook blocks pawn and
it seems like there's no way to protect
the pawn but this is why it was crucial
that if the black king is to enter the
game via king to h6 now it doesn't work
so again I asked you to pause the video
here and try to find a couple Blancas
idea what happens after rook to d8 I
once again I'll give you a couple of
seconds for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations you are an
excellent endgame player and for those
of you who just wanna enjoy it show
Knight g8 check this is of course the
problem now if you just move the King by
taking g6 the Nitra maneuvers himself to
f6 the knight now is defending the pawn
and it's all over
Bishop to c7 is coming and it's
is game over so here after night 2 g8
check this was played in the game by
Capablanca one Corzo captured the night
and now comes the shock to have sex
simply control the d8 square we have
king the g6 attacking the bishop but now
comes upon to d8 with widowed Queen rook
captures and Bishop captures tier kappa
blanka has two points and the bishop
against three pawns black does have a
passed pawn here but it's of little use
but like we said one course I found a
very interesting idea how he can try to
draw this game so we're gonna show it
you know gladly b5 by black we have king
- f2 Capablanca starts bringing his King
into the game King to f5 and now comes
King III with King e5 King to d3 you
don't gain anything by pushing the pawn
as bishop c7 check will simply pick it
up
so King d5 King comes to c3 and now
comes g3 Bishop to h4 attacks the pawn
pawn to g2 and now Bishop to have two
controlling the G 1 square so how does
kappa blanka win this now we have a 5
and here this was one course was planned
if kappa blanka plays a4 or perhaps here
perhaps he doesn't know how to go about
this game then the game would end in a
draw this is the problem here 1 course
you can simply capture and after pawn
captures then you see you have the wrong
Bishop because you only have one pawn
and that pawn Queens on a light Square
and you have a dark square bishop so
this is a draw however you play this but
we're just gonna show it later let's say
King c8 King c4 King b7 black just has
to occupy the corner and it's a draw
king b5 let's taking it in captures here
King b8
now the King can move to start bringing
the point of the board but let's say
King here a5 king b8 a6 King to 8 a 7
and now black was simply for our Queen
has pawn and after the Queen is captured
it's a draw the King and pawn create a
wall against the black King it is
stalemate so for those of you who are
perhaps new to chests and perhaps you
didn't know this but if you have a
position like this you don't want to
create a past a pawn because this pawn
Queen's on light Square and you have a
dark square Bishop so Capablanca please
be
or of course now if bone is captured
then you will have a beep on but one
course of course ignores this he plays
King to e4
we have Bishop to b6 now attacking the
a5 pawn and now comes King back to d5
and we have King to d3 we have King to
c6 and now Bishop back to g1 now
capablanca is just using his Bishop to
outmaneuver the black king we have king
bee 5 black now again reaches opposition
but capablanca doesn't care simply
Bishop to h2 forcing the King to move
either forcing the King to move or to
lock the position here and then slowly
but surely white King will improve his
position if you capture again white will
then have a beep on which will soon be a
passed pawn and of course it will be a
winning pawn
also notice that if you ever capture
with the be phone here point here B
captures here then it will still be a
draw you will even if you pick up the
both of the black pawns you will still
have to a pawns and both of them are
queening on a light square so still a
draw it doesn't matter if you have six
of them
so here couple one hasn't played a story
one course goes King back to c6 he is
trying to repeat the position but now
using the bishop capablanca forced the
King to move away out of opposition and
King D 4 starts improving the position
of his own King a for blocking the
position but now King e5 the King comes
off the board King b6 we have Kings to
d5 King to a6 and here kappa blanka
played King to c5 and now there are no
squares for the black king to go to to
keep protecting the pawns and it was in
this position that one Corso resigned
the game
what if you resign after he moves King
captures here then King cappers here and
then with the two connected passed pawns
of course it's it's a winning position
but before I forget that in that very
cool moment where I believe it's moved
31 yeah a root 2 gee someone was played
the Queen has been sacrificed pawn
captures on f7 was played so the rook is
still pinned here one course will played
h6 and we said that Capablanca played
night before here attack the Queen and
then
look Queen captures an f1 was played but
there is a there is an even greater move
the move is actually Knight to h4 but
this move was found the fountain much
much after this game was played
I believe the engine ripka was the first
to have discovered this move as part of
also mentions in his book my great and
great predecessors that Papa Blanca was
somewhat lazy and if capablanca actually
started calculating and in that
variation where Knight it comes to d4
saw that Queen captures on f1 would
would have prolonged the game maybe he
would have decided to start calculating
and found ninety to h4 night to h4 is a
really powerful move because the the
threat is very simple
the threat is we already mentioned the
Queen cannot move the Queen has to
constantly keep an eye on the e8 where
the thread is Knight g6 check the route
will not be able to capture it and after
the king goes to h7 then the pawn can be
promoted as the knife from g6 will also
be controlling the f8 square and it's
game over on the other hand if you
capture the pawn then comes rook to g1
and now with the bishop and the route
from g1 attacking the rook and g7 it's
game over whatever black plays let's say
Queen d7 then you get Bishop captures on
g7 King 2h here and now you get you can
even bring a knight into the game with
check force black the capture it
captures Bishop captures and now you
have two looks and the bishop against
the Queen but also it's a force mate in
11 rook rook to g7 is coming a rope here
is coming not much you can do here you
can give a couple of checks Queen c7
check White will walk now you can try
Queen c2 check again rogue g2 blocking
Queen d3 and now Rock e7 check it will
be will be winning
King h8 Bishop to g7 check o King g8
Bishop e5 check King goes here and now
after Bishop to f4
there is no defense against the bishop
captures on h8 checkmate
whatever you play let say Queen f3
Bishop captures on h6 is checkmate so a
very interesting move it's also 43 moves
instead of 63 moves that was played in
the actual game but yeah I think either
Capablanca saw
he's entering an end game which is
winning that he saw that that Bishop and
Knight will be creating a wall against
the black King so the black king will
not be able to enter the game so but I
remember when I read that a couple
Blancas book so okay what's the name of
it it's a serious I can't remember it I
put it in the description block but he
often after finishing the game he often
show the way how he could have won the
game using a combination it's instead of
just playing but as capablanca always
said if you have to complicate chess
then you don't understand chess if
there's a simple win just go for it so
yeah alright that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I do hope you enjoyed
both of both Blancas idea and the idea
that was found much later after a game
was played I would like to thank
Johannes crusher its last role of forest
Nicholas correct - Erik LaBelle and Kurt
Mulder for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here they will now both be games
by josé raúl capablanca thank you all
and I will see you soon with some more
interesting content by the cube
ingenious Jose roll kappa blanka thank
you all and I'll see you soon